- One thing on the resolution is,
is getting married this year.
- I was gonna say, yes.
- Yes.
- I love that, that's already a huge thing
getting married and planning that,
if you're doing a big wedding
and you're not eloping,
that's huge but you're
also doing a 50 city tour.
- Yes.
- Do you like to set yourself
up for failure?
I'm like what?
- I hear-
- Are you gonna be medicated
throughout this process?
That's a lot.
- Medicated with dance.
No, I'm so excited.
I'm so excited to go on tour.
It's the first time I've
gone on tour in four years.
- Really?
- Yes and so this show
is gonna be unlike-
- I guess 'cause COVID
as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- But it's also really special
is that I've never toured with Hailey
since we've been together.
- [Kelly] Didn't y'all meet on tour?
- We did. We met on tour
for something else.
- Who hit on who?
Who opened the door?
- Oh, whoa.
- Who opened the door?
- I mean, I think we
both opened the door
- I'm not saying anything.
- simultaneously, maybe.
- You just said, "Simultaneously."
- I did the head move, didn't I?
- You did.
- I did.
- I was just wondering, it's I don't know.
I was wondering who made the
first move, I don't know.
- It was fully him.
- Do you know what's funny?
- It was me, it was me.
- He's like, "I'm gonna make
a story about this."
But I'm like, "No, it's definitely him."
- I would say, there was a moment where
we were actually on stage dancing.
We're doing a rumba, the dance of love
and it was the last show and the dancers
from the side of the stage
were all like, "Kiss! Kiss!"
So our first kiss-
- A total junior high moment.
I love it.
- It really was.
- Yeah.
- Our first kiss was actually
on stage.
- On stage.
- Yeah.
- That's sexy.
- I know.
Yeah.
- I'd watch that movie.
Yeah, two dancers falling in love.
Oh, that's nice.